hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch the
black summer season one official trailer
this came out about three weeks ago
but it's coming out on Netflix I think
this week you see one of our top reward
tiers that our patreon pages whatever
video you're requesting must do and put
up on the youtubes and today comes from
our great friend
Jason Dolan you're coming out here
during the week at of endgame it's gonna
be tough making time to see you
but I'll try my best or lie my way out
of it anyway um actually the the one of
the stars of the show is Jaime King who
Jason Dolan is friends with in real life
as a matter of fact one shout out Jamie
King tagged us and recorded the shout
out on her social media and she probably
forgot all about who we are but if you
needed a reminder over Jaime King is and
she has a good chance of now seeing this
video she has been in such grand films
like bulletproof monk Cheaper by the
Dozen to the upcoming escape plan the
extractors and then some other smaller
films like yeah they're nothing like
those like ocean's 8 you know the Sin
City films fanboys blow you know like
those are whatever but those first three
I would like to get an autograph from
her on that
oh boy butter knife
[Applause]
you know I've loved the zombie [ __ ] so
much no yes
scared nipple chills
[Music]
[Applause]
I love music
oh man
even Bruce Willis and diehard would be
freaking out at that moment bad time to
be in a ventilation fan that's his
lighter go back go back
this looks cool man I mean the day were
watching this I had just learned about
how they have a third Walking Dead show
coming out oh boy
yeah just walking dead all day every day
now but this one takes place like a year
and a half before the outbreak it also
there's no regular people mm-hmm I think
I heard that exact joke on spring
Jeffy's news hey man it's a good day
everyone's making the joke all right
this though does seem like it's bringing
a different flare to it especially I
mean with the TV format with zombie
stuff there's been other zombie shows
outside of The Walking Dead but that one
has a much more slower pace to it this
feels very like visceral and kinetic and
like uncomfortably intimate in your
feeling a lot of these like handheld
shots right in the actors [ __ ] face
all the time yeah I love the way it
looks and the like you know with the
zombie genre you often explore some
other themes similar consequences
similar sacrifices similar choices you
got to make but it's all in the
execution of how attached are you to the
characters in their time and place you
know true and their tone of whatever the
series is I feel like there's something
different that's being brought to this
show Jason told us that this is sort of
like 28 days leader lately 28 days of
leaders leader gallon corny days later
needs loss which are two terrible
properties but I do think that maybe
together they'd be good that's like
Robert I gotta clarify when I'm joking
now because sarcasm graphic yeah I used
to insert it there's a much stronger
level of just immediacy and intensity
that I don't really see in the
television format for zombie shows that
I I kind of miss out on nowadays
especially
Walking Dead is often flip-flopping with
ratings and how audience is responding
because of how slow it can be I feel
like the ultimate solution is not to
something that's not such a slow burn
like that and do something that's very
medial and start off with like this
seems like it's picking up because it
with the whole quarantine situation and
soldiers and stuff that it's picking up
pretty much of the beginning of this
apocalypse
oh yeah that's definitely the sense I
get I would have expected the first
episode is going to start perhaps at the
tail end maybe of things being normal
and then throw you into the chaos of
this yeah because it's you know like a
nice suburb that there it's like a
cul-de-sac that they're on and looks
like and it's it's interesting that you
brought up twenty days later cuz that's
like the main stylistic takeaway I got
from this was you know as compared to a
lot of zombie shows which feature a more
classic Romero esque form of the
metaphor and the you know visual the
zombies and one because that I usually
lends itself to television format may be
as an amazing and stuff that you go
you're gonna hang out with the people
yeah it makes more sense we both the
zombies are slower so it would take them
longer to be attacking but first
cinematic scale to television this seems
to be the right fit oh yeah I mean the
the intensity really translates I mean
it looks like you said really visceral
really raw and really desperate in a lot
of ways and it looks like I mean again
you expect there to be a certain amount
of zombie action or outbreak action I
don't know what the nature is here and
people love to draw that line but you
know what they like to play
technicalities they're zombies okay
they're freaking zombies yeah they're
mindless eating machines perhaps and you
know then we have the other side and it
seems like they're really gonna play up
the psychological angles with the people
as we come to expect and so mainly what
I'm curious about now is just how this
trailer will translate to the show cuz
there's also a very stylized trailer
with a lot of staccato editing a lot of
black spaces in between specific images
so it's really enticing and now I wonder
how an actual episode is gonna play out
tonally because it's not necessarily I
would expect to be that frantic for you
know an entire 45 minutes but I love the
look of just the aesthetics I love the
look of the cast and everything like
that and how intense and nasty the
zombies look so and I like the set up in
terms of you know it's like a basic
emotional thing to get
you invested in like Jamie Kings
character but the idea of how she like
loses her daughter in the first episode
and she's kind of on this search for her
daughter
that's a immediate thing to get you to
latch on to a character for more than
just survive but also search and find
you know I think having that element
really eliminates anything that could be
just meandering hidden in a zombie-like
series but you know Netflix also has
South Korea to diet which is a wonderful
zombie show that I highly recommend you
guys go check out in fact just double
feature of these palate cleanses a
little santa clarita after you've gotten
your heavies out and dolan also said
that this is it's not the same DP but a
lot of the same people who did a lot of
the camera work for this show or the
same people who did the revenant and you
know how freaking awesome the revenant
looked and I could actually see shades
of that throughout this trailer so yeah
I think there's actually a lot to look
forward to yeah yeah that's pretty sweet
hey man Netflix is doing a whole lot of
stuff right now and this is a definitely
one of the trailers from them I've seen
recently they made me go I definitely
need to see the first episode all right
well JD my buddy I can't wait to see you
again my dear you know what I realized
now we had be great friends we might
text each other throughout the week but
dude many many months ago we got you a
t-shirt and I don't think we've ever
given you the t-shirt we signed that
real rejects tea for you and I've had
this note on our patron to dues for six
months now
Jason Dolan shirt holding on to and for
the next time I see him and I've
probably seen you about three times
since you live in Atlanta and you visit
here and I see you about three different
times since we've had that t-shirt and I
still haven't given it to you did we
really order it did we just pocket your
patreon contribution and just lied about
that and I just keep delaying and
procrastinating likely but and on alms
so it's like somewhere there in this
little pile I'm sure it's in a pile
we're uh we take turns rubbing it
against ours
is to kind of marinate it in our juices
so that we finally do give it to you
it's fully real reject off' I'd you know
that's it's it's yeah it's it's really
to make the shirt better for you and
more authentic because you know then you
can sell it on eBay for at least $100
true yeah true and can you yes Jamie
King - you know like just take a look at
this video chat around Instagram she's
got like over a million followers yeah
bring us on the show she's beautiful and
I just feel like whoever her followers
are we are very much into and we would
appeal that with guys the diagram really
overlaps definitely so I think it's a
win-win for both her and us guys you can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell and see God's
lighters